I wanted to say I loved the show I I
grew up on the on the film so watching
this brought back a lot of nostalgia for
me and I think the first thing I wanted
to ask you was related to that you know
you're coming into a world
with so much Nostalgia attached to it
it's a world that a lot of people love
and you know you're my age maybe you
didn't grow up with it you know the way
some people did how was it fitting into
that world you know was were their
nerves attached there or was it sort of
more natural especially since you're
working with Warwick Davis who's coming
back to this part after you know 30
years likewise I was a fan of the
original movie I was when I was a kid
um so when I got to join this you know
whole thing I was very excited and
honored and um yeah I mean look we had
all the
best creative team that we could have
um that you know gave us the belief
system or gave me the belief system and
um I wasn't too nervous to be honest
because even when I got to set I saw how
wonderful my co-stars were and how
wonderful the sets and costumes and
everything were and I just felt like all
right regardless I'm gonna have the best
time on this place and that's gonna make
me
feel way more comfortable yeah
I think that I definitely had some
nerves attached just simply because of
the like scale of the show and also like
the amount of detail and how much hard
work had gone into the show I mean
definitely we had like such an
incredible creative team to rely on but
I wasn't without my nerves but you know
you can get excited and so excited about
working on a show like this so you can
kind of change the nerves into
excitement after a while and Tony
specifically I wanted to ask you you're
sort of jumping between Disney
franchises you worked on the Spider-Man
film so now you're working on this is
there any similarity there or just sort
of you know magic and superheroes exist
in two different worlds for you no I
think there's a there's a bit of you
know
overlap in the Venn diagram of both
those things it might be not as big as
as you would imagine but regardless it's
um the same kind of core behind the
scene elements and being able to have
these creative conversations with people
in the scale of what uh is done
um so yeah it's a lot of that stuff but
you know living in a fantasy world uh is
is a big big change you know where we
were shooting and how we were shooting
them up in the mountains of Wales and
that was a
a big kind of
um switch for me and this role was a lot
more physical than I had to do in the um
uh Spider-Man franchise so uh there was
a lot more for me to do in that regard
and one last question the original film
is sort of so full of Hope and
perseverance so what do you guys hope
that people take away from this this
show I hope that they still take away
that hope and the fact that there are
you know everyone can be a hero and they
can be a Heritage of their own journey
and just a kind of sense of like
believing in yourself and and finding
your way in in the world awesome thank
you guys so much
thank you of course